we have witnessed history for the first
time ever Congress has criminally
referred a former president for criminal
prosecution even Nixon and Andrew
Johnson were never referred to the
justice department for criminal
prosecution but what does this mean what
is a criminal referral and what was the
January 6 committee basing its findings
on well throughout the January 6
committee's hearings this summer and
fall committee has presented evidence of
Donald Trump's attempt to remain in
power despite tens of millions of
Americans more importantly 306 real
members of The Electoral College which
are more important than millions of
Americans saying no they've also
presented eyewitness testimony
depositions about the way that Trump's
deranged insistence the election had
been stolen resulted in an armed and
deadly Insurrection on the Capitol
building the committee interviewed
Georgia Secretary of State Brad
raffensberger about his perfect phone
call with Donald Trump raffensberger
testified that Trump called him asking
him to find 11 000 ballots to help flip
Georgia from its blue reality the
committee heard testimony from a slew of
White House and other government
officials that they had told Trump that
his election denial stuff was absolutely
not correct but the Trump totally
ignored and disregarded their pleadings
there was memorable test somebody from
26 year old aide to Chief of Staff Mark
Meadows Cassidy Hutchinson who testified
that Meadows suggested he knew
beforehand about the Insurrection that
would happen on January 6th I found Mr
Meadows in his office on the couch I
remember leaning against the doorway and
saying I had an interesting conversation
as Rudy mark
sounds like we're going to go to the
Capitol
he didn't look up from his phone and
said things might get real real bad on
January 6th she also testified that
Trump wanted to give armed protesters
entry to where he was giving his speech
so much so that he demanded all metal
detectors or mags be removed from the
area he was angry that we weren't
letting people through the knives with
weapons I overheard the president say
something's the effect of Let My People
in they can March the capital from here
of course there was also the ketchup
anecdote I left the office and went down
to the dining room I first noticed there
was ketchup dripping down the wall and
there's a shattered porcelain plate the
president
was extremely angry and had thrown his
lunch against the wall but in the final
public hearing of the January 6
committee Benny Thompson and the other
eight members of the bipartisan group
laid out arguably the most damning
evidence of both Trump's apathy towards
the 2020 presidential election and
Trump's thundering silence for 187
minutes while insurrectionists overran
the capital Trump's White House counsel
Pat cipolloni and hope Hicks testified
to Trump's silence during the
Insurrection so are you aware of any
phone call by the president of the
United States to the Secretary of
Defense that day
not that I'm aware of you know but make
no mistake though Trump was definitely
busy strengthening his case for Section
1512 and 1505 obstruction the president
was making phone calls that afternoon
but they weren't law enforcement
officials rather president Trump
continued to call his lawyer Rudy
Giuliani
both president Trump and Mr Giuliani
spoke with Congressional leaders to
encourage them to continue delaying the
session finally the lawyers in the Trump
White House testified about his
nixon-esque plot to replace the Attorney
General with a Brazen sycophant
president Trump tried to install a
loyalist named Jeffrey Clark to leave
the department as acting attorney
general now that's just skimming the
surface for some of the evidence that
the January 6 committee Unearthed and
presented in support of their criminal
referrals but what is a congressional
criminal referral well a criminal
referral is a recommendation from a
congressional committee to the justice
department that based on certain
evidence the committee believes that
people committed certain crimes when
congress makes a criminal referral it
has no legal weight the Department of
Justice does not have to file criminal
charges just because Congress made a
referral congress makes law and the
executive branch enforces it but that
doesn't mean that the referral is just
Congress handing the doj a thick file
and saying good luck it is as we all
know by now unprecedented for Congress
to say that a president committed crimes
the committee's recommendation puts more
pressure on the justice department in
special prosecutor Jack Smith to go
forward with a prosecution and the
special prosecutor statute requires
Smith to explain the basis for whatever
action he takes including if he declines
to prosecute Trump but no doubt the
Department of Justice is going to be
less interested in the ultimate
recommendation of Congress and more
interested in the evidence that the
committee has gathered so let's talk
about the criminal referrals that were
made of former president Trump
representative Raskin said that the four
statutes that are named here are not the
only laws that former president Trump
potentially violated but they are the
most important ones the first is account
of obstruction of an official proceeding
under 18 USC 1512 which makes it illegal
to corruptly obstruct an official
proceeding the committee report
concluded that congress's joint session
to count electoral votes on January 6
was an official proceeding under Section
1512 and the report relies on the
decisions of the many federal judges who
have already reached this conclusion in
cases involving the January 6 defendants
as for whether Trump had the requisite
intent the committee concluded that
quote there should be no doubt that
President Trump knew that his actions
were likely to quote obstruct influence
or impede that proceeding and based on
the evidence developed president Trump
was attempting to prevent or delay the
counting of lawful certified Electoral
College votes from multiple States quote
president Trump was directly and
personally involved in this effort
personally pressuring vice president
Pence relentlessly as the joint session
on January 6 approached quote indeed in
an email exchange during the violence of
January 6 John Eastman admitted that
President Trump had been advised that
vice president Pence could not lawfully
refuse to count votes under the
Electoral count act but once he gets
something in his head it's hard to get
him to change course in addition
president Trump knew that he had lost
dozens of state and federal lawsuits and
that the justice department his campaign
and his other advisors concluded that
there was insufficient fraud to alter
the outcome president Trump also knew
that no majority of any state
legislature had taken or manifested any
intention to take any official action
that could change a state's Electoral
College votes and the effort to pressure
Mike Pence is just one possible
violation of 18 USC 1512. the committee
said that there is also evidence to
support charges quote based on the plan
to create and transmit to the executive
and legislative branches fraudulent
electoral slates which were ultimately
intended to facilitate an unlawful
action by vice president Pence to refuse
to count legitimate certified electoral
votes during congress's official January
6 proceeding in addition to the fake
electoral slates the committee found
evidence that Trump may have illegally
pressured state election officials state
legislators and others to quote alter
official electoral outcomes and finally
the report also says that Trump tried to
corrupt the Department of Justice citing
his commitment to the doj that all it
needed to do was quote just say that the
election was corrupt plus leave the rest
to me and the Republican Congressman the
committee also uncovered evidence that
Jeffrey Clark was instrumental in trying
to corrupt the Department of Justice and
further into the scheme to interfere
with the official proceeding of Congress
to certify the vote Jeffrey Clark was an
Assistant Attorney General
a trump appointee at the Department of
Justice
according to multiple sources Mr Clark
was asked by then president Trump to
take over the role of Attorney General
in part so he could issue a series of
letters falsely suggesting that the
Department of Justice believed the
presidential election may have been
stolen
of course this happened after the
department had repeatedly informed
president Trump that his allegations of
a stolen election were not true and were
not supported by the evidence
and this happened after dozens of Courts
had ruled against President Trump and
his election fraud claims Clark sent the
letter that cipolloni described as quote
a murder-suicide pact in the hope that
it would quote help persuade a state
legislature to change its certified
slate of electoral college electors
based on false allegations of fraud
which was then supposed to inspire Pence
to count a different slate on January
6th and according to the committee the
letter was transparently false improper
and illegal and in terms of the actual
Capital rights the committee says that
Trump's action inaction during the
January 6 Riot was more evidence of
intent to obstruct Congress he spent 187
minutes refusing to take any step to
stop the violence and instead Trump and
Rudy Giuliani called members of Congress
who were Sheltering in place to hide
from the attackers and ask them to go
along with the illegal Eastman plan and
impede the vote and the committee said
that Johnny Smith and Kenneth cheese bro
were instrumental in the conspiracy and
that representative Scott Perry and
other Republicans who have resisted
testifying likely have material facts
regarding Trump's plan to overturn the
election the SEC can count of the
criminal referral deals with conspiracy
to defraud the United States section 371
of Title 18 makes it legal to enter into
a criminal conspiracy to defraud the
United States the Supreme Court has
helped this statute criminalizes the use
of deceptive practices in connection
with any conspiracy for the purpose of
impairing obstructing or defeating the
lawful function of any Department of
government and conspiring to obstruct a
joint session of Congress from
certifying the election certainly
qualifies as seeking to obstruct a
lawful function of the government and
the committee generally alleges that
Trump and his co-conspirators followed a
seven-point plan first engage in a
concerted effort to spread false
information to the American public that
the 2020 election was stolen second to
orchestrate a corrupt scheme between
Trump Chief of Staff Mark Meadows and
representative Scott Perry to replace
the acting attorney general who rejected
Trump's fraud claims with Trump's doj
Ally Jeffrey Clark to use the Department
of Justice to overturn the election
third to implement Eastman's plan to
pressure vice president Pence to refuse
to count or delay the certification of
the Electoral account fourth to pressure
state election officials and state
legislators to change election results
fifth to instruct Republicans to create
false electoral slates in seven
Battleground States and transmit those
fake slates to Congress and the National
Archives six to summon up a mob in the
U.S Capitol and seventh during the
attack on the capital to ignore pleas
for help and tacitly endorse the
violence including threats to hang Mike
Pence as for proof that individuals use
deceitful or dishonest means the
committee says that there were two areas
where Trump and his friends were
deceitful starting with their insistence
the election was fraudulent and that
Trump defeated Joe Biden there's
actually an incredibly damning chart on
page 17 of the committee's report
outlining what the lawyers were saying
that there wasn't election fraud versus
what Trump was saying that there was
mass election fraud for example Trump
showed then Deputy Attorney General
Jeffrey Rosen a videotape that
supposedly showed a suitcase full of
ballots Rosen explained to Trump that
this was actually quote a bin that's
what they use when they're counting
ballots it's benign one week later Trump
repeated the conspiracy claim quote
there is even the security camera
footage from Georgia that shows
officials telling poll Watchers to leave
the room before pulling suitcases of
ballots out from under the tables and
continuing to count for hour hours
attorney general Bill Barr and Deputy
A.G Richard Donahue debunked Trump's
Michigan and Pennsylvania voter fraud
claims but once again Trump ignored what
they were saying and made up his own
facts Trump followed the same pattern
with other conspiracy theories about
Dominion voting machines and as to
motive the committee says that first of
all it helped Trump raise money quote
evidence gathered by the committee
indicates that President Trump raised
roughly one quarter of a billion dollars
in fundraising efforts between the
election and January 6th these
solicitations persistently claimed and
referred to the election fraud that did
not exist and the second reason Trump
lied about election fraud was to
obstruct the January certification
proceedings quote Trump disregarded the
rulings of the courts and rejected the
findings and collusions and advice from
his justice department his campaign
experts and His White House and cabinet
advisors he chose instead to try to
overturn the election on January 6th and
took a series of very specific steps to
attempt to achieve that result and this
is all related to the third element of a
conspiracy that the person takes at
least one overt act in furtherance of
the conspiracy for Trump to achieve the
desired result he had to get Mike Pence
to ignore the Constitutional duties you
might recall that the 12th amendment
gives the Vice President in their role
as the president of the Senate the job
of certifying the result of the
presidential election quote the
president of the Senate shall in the
presence of the Senate and the House of
Representatives open all of the
certificates and the votes shall then be
counted the person having the greatest
number of votes for president shall be
the president the Electoral count Act of
1887 reiterates that the vice
president's role is ministerial in that
his job is just to count the votes not
to choose which votes to count and which
to reject but while Trump was being told
that he lost the election lawyer John
Eastman and others quote devised a plan
whereby vice president Pence wood as a
presiding officer declare that certain
electoral votes from certain States
could not be counted at the Joint
session John Eastman knew before
proposing this plan that it was not
legal despite knowing that the plan was
illegal Trump pursued it anyway
including for the 187 minutes when the
attack happened Congress was being
evacuated to underground tunnels and
even after he was aware that the mob was
chanting about hanging my Pence count
three of the criminal referral refers to
a conspiracy to make false statements
under 18 USC 1001 this is the classic
lying to the government provision and
this count was about Trump conspiring
with other people to submit slates of
fake electors to Congress in the
National Archives these certificates
were patently false since Biden won each
of those States and the state's
authorities certified Biden's Victory
now In fairness whether a statement or
act is material for the purposes of
section 1001 can be a contentious issue
but here the report says that at best
quote it can hardly be disputed that the
false slates of electors were material
as nothing can be more material to the
Joint session of Congress to certify the
election than the question of which
candidate won which states indeed
evidence obtained by the committee
suggests that those attempting to submit
certain of the electoral votes regarded
the need to provide that material to
vice president Pence as urgent the
bigger question is whether the various
people making the certificates and
submitting them acted knowingly and
willfully some of those individuals who
sign their names to fake certificates
said that they thought that they'd only
be used if Trump prevailed in litigating
in their states Paving the way for
Trump's win in those states to be
certified making their fake certificates
valid and okay to submit to the National
Archives and to Congress but that's not
the case with most of the executive
branch here since Trump acting through
his co-conspirators like Eastman and
cheese bro relied on the existence of
those fake electors as a basis for
asserting that the the vice president
could reject or delay the certification
of the Biden electors the people who
believe that they were serving as
alternate electors in case Trump
prevailed in court might not have known
that Trump and Eastman were collecting
the certificates for another reason to
persuade Pence to implement their
illegal plan but the committee alleges
that the higher-ups including Donald
Trump knew what they were doing and
personally participated in this plan
quote the evidence is clear that
President Trump personally participated
in a scheme to have the Trump electors
meet cast votes and send their votes to
the Joint session of Congress in several
states that Vice President Biden won and
then his supporters relied on the
existence of these fake electors as part
of their effort to obstruct The Joint
session and to proven overt acting
further of a conspiracy the committee
relies on the testimony of Republican
National Committee chairwoman Rona
McDaniel she told the committee that
Trump and Eastman directly requested
that the RNC organized the effort to
have the fake electors meet and cast
their votes and that she complied with
their request and then the fourth count
of the criminal referral is for inciting
assisting or aiding an Insurrection in
violation of 18 USC 2383. until the
events of January 6 2021 there had been
no prosecutions under Section 2383 since
the Civil War the Insurrection statute
was enacted in 1862 as a precursor to
the Emancipation Proclamation and there
was an 1863 circuit court case that held
that the Act was unconstitutional
because it punished the same conduct
it's treason and treason was only
applicable if a foreign country levied
war against the United States since 1863
the Supreme Court has implied but has
not yet ruled that it would reject the
Insurrection as an end run around
treason argument president Trump was
acquitted of incitement to Insurrection
in his second impeachment trial but
since this was not a Judicial trial
there's no double jeopardy any problem
however it's not easy to get a
conviction under the statute because it
implicates the first amendment the
committee relied on a recent court
opinion to assert that Trump's speech
wasn't protected by the first amendment
in Thompson versus Trump a judge on the
DC circuit ruled that the statements
Trump made during his ellipse speech
before the riot uh quote were plausibly
words of incitement not protected by the
First Amendment this was a civil case
where 11 members of the U.S House of
Representatives and two Capitol police
officers sued Trump seeking damages for
physical injuries and emotional distress
from January 6. the Court ruled that
Trump would not necessarily be able to
invoke presidential immunity in
defending the claim but you can imagine
something that is arguably political
speech is going to receive the highest
amount of first amendment protection so
we'll see how this one goes the
committee argues that it doesn't need to
prove that Donald Trump was actually in
contact with the actual rioters or that
there was evidence of an actual
agreement between the president and the
writers quote the president need only
have incited assisted or aided and
comforted those engaged in violence or
other Lawless activity in an effort to
prevent the peaceful transition of the
presidency under our constitution but as
an interesting code here although the
Congressional criminal referrals carry
no legal weight Jack Smith who attorney
general Merrick Garland appointed as
special counsel in charge of looking
into these crimes at least as it regards
Donald Trump and others in that orbit
sent a letter to the select committee
requesting all the panel's materials
from the 18-month probe so the special
prosecutor is looking into the evidence
if not the referrals themselves but if
the doj picks up the criminal referrals
whether they convict on any of these
counts will largely depend on whether
they can prove Trump's mental state and
luckily I made a video all about whether
Donald Trump has the Criminal Intent
necessary for conviction but you can
only see it with today's sponsor
curiosity stream and nebula because on
nebula my videos always come out early
with zero ads and I release exclusive
content all the time like this video
that is exclusive about Trump's mental
state it was it was hard to make did you
some would say what mental state or an
entire video about legal stories they're
not safe for work because they're too
hot for YouTube as well as exclusive
videos like things people misunderstand
about the Constitution why nfts are bad
for creators and my first full-length
documentary bad law words good and tons
more all exclusive to nebula because
nebula is Creator owned and Creator
operated there's new exclusive content
released every single day in fact Johnny
Harris just signed with nebula and you
can see all of his videos a week early
only on nebula first and by the way
we've been developing nebula like crazy
nebula now has apps for iOS Android
Apple TV Roku Fire TV Android TV and it
was recently nominated for its second
streamy award my fellow creators and I
really care about nebula and we're
thrilled to be partnering with
curiositystream because they're the
go-to source for the best documentaries
in long-form educational content on the
internet they even have an entire
section devoted to Unsolved Mysteries
and crime so if you like my videos you
love the thousands of titles on
curiosity stream but the best way to get
access to nebula and all this incredible
content is through the amazing curiosity
stream nebula bundle deal with his
current sale of 42 off that's less than
twelve dollars a year to get access to
both sites and to be clear that nebulous
description it's not a trial it's free
for as long as you're a member of
curiosity stream there just isn't a
better deal in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites with content
that you'll actually watch all for less
than twelve dollars for the entire year
at his current sales price and it's 42
off so all you have to do is click on
the link that's on screen right now or
down in the description to get 42 off
both curiosity stream and get nebula for
free so just click now on the link
that's on screen or down in the
description it's a great way to support
educational content and get tons of
exclusive content that you'll actually
love so click right now and after that
click on this playlist over here for
more legal eagle or I'll see you in
court